[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spider-man and with the
first mega face of the MCU being wrapped
up in what is now known as the infinity
saga I thought I'd look back over the
past eleven years of Marvel movies to
break down the best Easter egg this
consistency ran all the way from Iron
Man up to Avengers endgame and it's the
perfect example of just how much
attention to detail that Marvel Studios
really put into their movies it also
carries with it a lot of foreshadowing
which I'll get into later but it's one
of the neatest little Easter eggs in a
film that I've ever seen now there will
be heavy spoilers here so if for
whatever reason you aren't fully up to
speed with the MCU then I highly
recommend that you turn off now without
the way I just want to give a huge thank
you for clicking this video now let's
get into my breakdown of the best MCU
Easter Egg okay so the first major
consistency that carries all the way
through the Infinity Saga is Iron Man's
arm injury this little detail appears
throughout every film that the character
is in and gets worse and worse over time
that longer things go on he first
sustains this during his self-titled
origin movie on his escape from the cave
Iron Man gets his arm stuck in a rock
and has to yank it out and then later he
damages it further on his first mission
when he travels to the Middle East to
defeat the hostile forces that held him
captive Iron Man is blasted out of the
sky by a tank that hits him right in his
left shoulder and sends him flying to
the ground whilst the characters should
be able to just shake this off this home
again is badly damaged during the next
film in Iron Man 2 when reviewing his
suit damaged after his battle with
whiplash we can see once again that his
armor is severely damaged in this
location this is due to not only his arm
being set on fire before the fight but
also because he went head-to-head with
the villain and took one of his whips
directly to his limb skip to the next
film after iron man crash lands in the
wilderness in Iron Man 3
he wants more sits up and goes for his
arm which will no doubt be in a lot of
pain an age of Ultron during the
Hulkbuster fight his arm gets a lamppost
thrust through it by the Hulk and all
these injuries just continue to mount up
and up fast-forward to Civil War and
when Tony's with Captain America he pays
lip service to the injury by saying that
his arm is numb and asking if that's
normal in the airport scene when going
toe-to-toe with Hawkeye and Scarlet
Witch the latter throws several cars at
him in order to bury him and we can
clearly see one landing directly on his
left arm once more making the injury
even worse later in the movie Tony is
seen nursing it in a sling and before
suiting up to go and meet cap and Bucky
for the final battle he can be seen
holding it during the fight with the two
Tony falls directly on his left arm
once more causing a lot more damage when
reading caps letter at the end of the
phone we can visibly see Tony stank
I mean Starks arm and the latter shaking
which shows that he has now gained some
nerve damage to it and is unable to
properly hold the limb completely still
next up is spider-man homecoming in
which he can be seen resting and
steadying at once more and taking away
the suit from the webhead the first
thing he does when stepping out of the
armor is to grab his wrist which shows
that he's still suffering a lot of pain
from it jump forward to infinity war and
when going head-to-head with Dan oz Tony
uses all of his nanotech on his arm to
make a blade which fails to take down
the Titan and then the character gets
injured once more after being stabbed by
his own weapon
well it's he doesn't sustain any massive
injuries directly here he still hurt
when being pushed back on his bad arm
and when Spiderman dies right in front
of him the character can be seen once
more holding his wrist now you may be
wondering why I even bother to make a
video about all of this but it all comes
to a head in Avengers and game when Tony
wheels Infinity Gauntlet a complete
opposite to Thanos Tony decides to wear
the gauntlet on his right hand
even though Thanos did it with the left
purely because it's his weaker arm Tony
just doesn't want to potentially risky
using the gauntlet on his bad hand and
thus he deliberately picks the opposite
side just in case he needs to wheel the
stones at some point it's a nice little
bit of foreshadowing that was
highlighted at the beginning of the MCU
when we get a heavy focus on Iron Man's
left arm the first time that we ever see
him in the film
now this last part is pretty much a fan
theory but I think it makes a lot of
sense
you is amazing at foreshadowing and I
can't think of any other reason why they
deliberately kept bringing back his arm
injury over and over again
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it and if you spotted an even better
easter egg then make sure you leave it
in the comments section below if you
want something else to watch after this
then make sure you check out my
breakdown of every time that Mysterio
appeared in the background of a scene
during spider-man far from home which
would be linked at the end I go over all
of the early appearances before the two
characters beat so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more if
you want to come talk to me about movies
TV shows games and comic books and you
can follow me on twitter at definition
whitey it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content so
hopefully I see you over there after
this also just one let you know that
we're giving away a free copy of
spider-man far from home on blu-ray and
all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is to like this video
make sure that you subscribe to the
channel and leave me thoughts on this
Easter Egg in the comments section below
the winner will be chosen at random on
October the 15th and the blue arrow be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprise it's the best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is a
channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]